My name is Mr. Brown and this is
a video for my second grade language class
during the coronavirus quarantine in Comayagua, Honduras.
Hello everybody, I hope all of you are
happy and that you are washing your hands.
Today our objective is to spell common verbs
and pronounce them correctly by watching a slideshow
and writing the words together.
Does anybody know what a verb is?
A verb is an action word.
Do you remember when we played Simon Says
a couple of weeks ago?
Yes?
What are some of the words that you
learned from Simon Says?
Here are some that I remember.
Play, walk, run, eat, jump, stomp, clap,
drink, read, write, sit, close, open.
Do you know any others?
Do you remember more?
Let's practice together some more.
I will test you on your pronunciation later.
For this activity, you're going to need a
pencil and a piece of paper.
Watch the images and write the word for
the images that you see.
When you understand the images, you will be
able to play a communication game with your
classmates.
Let's do this activity together first.
Okay, number one is clap, clap,
like that.
Number two, number two is close,
close, like that.
Number three, number three is drink, drink,
drink, drink.
Number four is eat,
eat, eat, eat.
Number five is jump, j-u-m-p.
J-u-m-p, j-u-m-p.
Number six is open, o-p, open,
open.
Number seven, play, p-l-a-y.
Number eight, number eight is read, r-e
-a-d, read.
Number nine, number nine is run, n
-r-u-n.
Number 10 is sit, s-i
-t, not e, not seat, s-i-t,
sit.
Number 11, 11 is stomp, s-t,
stomp.
Number 12 is walk, walk.
This letter is silent, walk.
Last one, number 13, 13, write, write.
This letter is silent, write.